well
[Music]
hello how are you I am salt and jaramillo with
the most outstanding headlines for
today Tuesday November 10 the
clark county school district presents a
proposal to start classes in
person again the students
will be in a hybrid way some days
in the classrooms  and others at home this
proposal consists of only having 50
percent capacity in the classrooms
as students will be divided into
groups measures such as the use of masks and
good hygiene practices
will also be mandatory
the southern nevada health district
is  offering
free covet screening at
ryan high school on thursday and friday of
this week site will be open
from 8am to noon no
appointment needed first come first
served unemployment will continue to
pay for fourth  week the money under
the job loss assistance program
that $300 per week
awarded
those who receive $100 or more
in their weekly benefits are
eligible also those who were
accepted for the pandemic unemployment program
you do not need to do anything to
get this help and now we pass with
the weather forecast we will have
temperatures rolling in the 59  degrees
despite the fact that it will be sunny it will be very
cold for the rest of the week we will see
a slight rise in temperatures
around 60 have a nice day I am
sali jaramillo and this was your brief
information on inclusion in Spanish
[Music]